My voice is dead from Minecraft, but I'm also dead.
Hello.
Hello, my voice.
Sorry.
I talked too much yesterday, probably.
Today?
Yesterday.
But I'm here.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Welcome, everybody.
I'm sleepy.
If you don't know why I'm sleepy...
You can check out the stream prior to this one.
Minecraft.
Sorry if I'm like...
Because my throat's... Actually, I have cough drops.
I have some... some...
This one.
There's a throat.
Mint.
Come out!
There we go.
Nom, nom, nom.
Is she tired from that short Minecraft stream earlier?
Oh, yeah.
Minecraft is just too exhausting for me to do for any number of hours.
How long was that?
What, like two, three hours, I think?
Minecraft therapy finds...
Thank you!
No, I had so much fun, if you watched it, thank you.
And...
Um...
Yeah.
It was fun.
Today, I want to do something really chill.
Today, I was just like, I don't know what I want to do.
Especially because I was like, I don't know how long Doki and I will be going for.
And so...
I was like, well, you know, I probably should...
I should... I should... What's the word?
I should not pace myself, but I should...
I should... Oh my gosh, what's happening?
I should first see... What are these?
I should first see how I'm feeling.
So it was between this and Astro Bot.
It was between this and Astro Bot.
Decompress.
Maybe.
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Yeah.
Only hour 8 into Minecraft live, but can confirm this is my new favorite stream of all time.
Funny because the previous title holder also involved two dorks playing Minecraft.
That was... It was just unbelievable how insane...
The stream turned out.
You know, I still feel a little stinky about having died to that drowned.
You know, I know some people are like, oh, this is why you don't play with shaders.
This is why you just play normal Minecraft because you would have been able to see the exit with the shaders on.
But honestly, if we had gotten to the stronghold, I think I would have just...
I would have just...
But it's okay.
You were fine, Minto.
Thanks.
Thank you.
The stronghold trials is BS.
We would have gotten in there and...
It would have probably been like another three hours, not gonna lie.
It probably would have been if we had survived.
It would have been like another three hours trying to find the portal.
Getting through the trials, maybe.
It would have been...
But anyway, if you're curious, if you're just like, what the heck is this annual ghost town pumpkin festival?
Minto, I don't know what this is.
I actually found this.
Okay, this is gonna sound stupid, but I get so many things that I find because my TikTok is not ultimately cursed.
It's only a little bit cursed.
And I actually found this on TikTok.
And it's like a yearly game that this dev puts out where people can join and carve pumpkins and then just walk around and meet other ghosts.
And it's just kind of cute.
And I was like, oh.
This seems fun.
And it has an escape room, which I've never done an escape room before ever, ever, ever, ever in my afterlife.
So I was like, I want to do one.
We can do escape room.
And lots of people can join.
So...
The game is free.
You just search the game on itch.io and you can find it.
But you can also donate to get extra...
Extra thingies.
Still watching the Minecraft collab and it is exactly the kind of stream that got me hooked on YouTube.
Make sure to rest up and never stop.
Thank you.
Thank you, Xanthox.
So...
You have to do an IRL.
There's so much fun with the right people.
I don't have...
People to do it with, maybe.
So...
I've always wanted to try it though.
I've always wanted to do one.
But...
Yeah.
I think my friends...
I don't know if my friends would like it.
It's my birthday today.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Rejoy.
Happy birthday!
Yeah, so this is kind of Halloween themed, but it's also fall themed.
So it's fine.
And it's only one week.
I think today is the last day that we can play.
So, let's first design my ghost.
Oh, oh no.
Wait, you can't see my name.
Bleakly...
Bleakly is a bat.
What does that mean?
Wait, if I randomize, will it change my name too?
Smile.
Why is it giving me the Roblox smile?
The Moonlight Sonata, why?
I kind of like this one though.
Oh my god, I'm the Roblox smile man!
Let's see, which one fits me?
Oh, this one.
You guys!
Wait...
It's literally you!
It's literally you guys!
Let's see what hats we got.
Do they have a maid?
This might be the easiest.
Oh my god, we can become Toad!
I can't do the voice right now though.
I kind of want to be a nurse, that's a little sexy.
We're on the telly!
You're in the game!
There's no maid, that's so sad.
Oh, it needs to be unlocked in the festival.
Oh, interesting.
I can be a bunny girl.
I'll be a bunny girl, that's kind of sexy.
So, if you see me, I'm Bleakly, easy bat.
You can't change your name, that's just me.
That's just me.
I'm the bat.
I'm the bat ghost.
Cool!
Wait, some of the pumpkins disappeared, right?
Oh, they move around!
Alright, let's carve a pumpkin.
Select a pumpkin to start carving.
Hot dog!
I rushed to finish all my work this week so I can go to Japan next week without guilt.
But that also means I get to fully experience yesterday's stream on the job.
Very well.
Otsu David!
Why do you have bunny ears, bat ghost?
I don't know.
I want something kind of ugly.
Like a misshapen pumpkin.
This one's kind of nice.
This one's huge!
I'm going to be the biggest pumpkin in the pumpkin patch.
Oh my gosh, guys.
What is this?
Toggle lighting.
Scrape and cut.
Visit the festival.
Save.
New pumpkin.
More.
Okay.
The Minecraft collab was low-key my dopamine dose to get me through finance month and work.
Thank you.
Ghost admin, thank you!
What should we... Okay.
What should we... What should we cut?
What should we...
What should we carve?
Hello!
How are you doing?
It's my first stream.
Welcome, welcome!
Thanks for joining.
This stream was so much fun.
I'm so glad you guys liked it.
Self-portrait?
Self-portrait.
Make the wisp, the funny wispy laugh?
What if I... Okay, hold on.
If I put this on, we can do this.
Okay.
Alright, I'm going to become... I'm going to do like a Metal Gear Minto.
Okay, Metal Gear Minto.
What a coincidence, it's my first stream too.
Oh my gosh, Todokete!
Name I've never seen before.
Welcome to stream!
Yeah, for anyone... Wait, what's this?
Wait, why can't I...
No, that's not what I wanted to do.
Wait, maybe I need to scrape.
Oh, interesting.
You can't control the size either, you just scrape.
For anyone wondering, I went to sleep around 7am, 7.30am.
I woke up at 10am.
No, I woke up at... Yes, that's true.
I woke up at 10am because my alarm went off.
And then I was like, no, two more hours.
And so I then...
I then slept until 12.
Okay, portrait of me.
Wearing the eyepatch.
Oh wait, I don't like that, that's ugly.
Gosh, pumpkins are hard, they're lumpy.
It's making my face all lumpy.
I look like an actual goblin.
Wait, I'm looking really... Is this what I look like?
I look like a real goblin right now.
Okay, hold on.
And the cross.
It's warping, it's warping.
Did you guys carve some pumpkins?
I wanna go see your pumpkins in the world, okay?
But, you know, I might not get to... I wanna find them naturally, so don't be like, hey, go find my pumpkin.
Oh my god, it's warping, it's warping.
It's warping.
Is this my... Wait, is this my smile?
Or is this my...
What is this?
I have a double chin.
Wait, what did I do here?
Huh?
You're asking us?
It's outlined to show the hair behind.
Nah, we'll keep it as my smile.
My very wide smile.
Oh wait, I don't have to draw the ahoge?
Look at this, it's kind of genius.
This is the ahoge.
This is my ahoge.
That little top of the pumpkin.
I'm very... Wait, hold on, let me redo it then.
Like that.
See it?
See it, see it.
Mint has an ahoge.
Yeah.
I've had one since 1.0.
Well, I had one in 1.0.
And then I got rid of it, because I brushed my hair.
And then I gave up brushing my hair.
I said, I hate brushing my hair.
I'm going back, I don't care about brushing my hair.
And that's how I got the ahoge back.
It's our beloved wide smile, Minto.
And I have ribbons.
Ribbons, and then hair.
More hair.
Can I turn this, or...
Will everybody only get to see it, like, from...
One angle.
I can't see what I'm doing on the side.
I feel like I should cut out a part, though.
Maybe I should cut out the eye.
You can rotate it?
How?
Guys, it's just...
It's blowing in the breeze, okay?
Right click.
It's blowing in the breeze.
I'm gonna sign it.
Nice.
Now everybody will know it's me.
They'll be like, what?
That's her!
That's me right there!
Oh gosh.
You think anybody will want to watch me, though?
Maybe, hold on, let me write...
Wait, this is the last day, probably no one will see this.
But just in case someone sees it, I'm...
A...
Vtuber.
Be careful.
I don't want someone being like, oh, Mint Phantom, that's such a...
Striking and provocative...
Pumpkin, I should go check them out.
And then they see I'm a Vtuber and they're like...
Real jumpscare!
It's just a thought-provoking pumpkin here.
You know?
Do we have enough room for subscribe?
Oh, baby, yeah we do.
Sub...
Scribe...
Subscribe.
Oh, look, it's a follow the message, you know?
Put a QR code on it?
It's just an ad.
No, it's not.
Okay, um...
I gotta put my...
Itai kakushi on here.
And then my maid headdress.
Do you think it looks just like me?
Oh, wait, I tried to give myself eyelashes.
Bottom lashes.
Okay.
Oha Mint!
And then I gotta also be saluting.
Okay, you can't tell what that is.
Nevermind.
This should be good.
I think it's a good advertisement.
Subscribe.
Mint Phantom.
I'm a Vtuber.
Me.
Does this look good?
Save?
What if I save it?
What happens?
Name my creation.
Mint...
Pump...
Um...
Hold on.
We're still in the drawing.
Mint...
Fan-kin.
I think the first one's better.
Absolute Jack-o'-lantern.
If it ain't Saucy Jack.
Saucy Jack!
There we go!
It's Saucy Jack!
If it ain't Saucy Jack.
There we go!
Saved.
Alright guys, we're gonna go to the festival.
I'm nervous to go to the festival.
I'm excited though.
I'm excited.
Oh my gosh!
There's so many people here.
There's so many tiny people here.
What is that sound?
Oh my god.
Oh, people are...
Oh, what is that sound?
What is that clicky sound?
It's terrible.
Oh my god.
What is that sound?
Oh, it's horrible.
Oh my god.
Am I here?
Hold on.
Excuse me.
Oh, it's No-Face.
So cute.
What's this one?
Timidly Scruffy Pumpkin.
Oh, this one is fun.
Wait, excuse me.
I'm trying to say.
I'm not here.
What is this?
Revolting.
Is that like the check your engine light?
Oh, it's the camera shutter.
I can chat here.
I'm gonna freak.
Oh my god, you guys.
It's so annoying.
How do I turn off the camera sound?
Wait, I can place my pumpkin somewhere.
Hold on.
Audio.
Oh, but I can't hear the ghost anymore I think, but it's peace and quiet.
Peace and quiet.
I don't get it, Paul.
Hello everybody!
Hello!
Boo!
Can I take a photo of you?
Sure!
This is weird.
This is like a real paparazzi experience.
Let's go explore some, you guys.
I haven't really been in here.
I just tested it out earlier.
I tested it out earlier to see if anybody was playing.
Read me.
And there was one other person.
And I said boo at them and they said, I'm a ghost.
Welcome to the 1004th Pumpkin Festival.
Look out for new areas like the Maze of Madness and the Hayride of Horror.
Feel free to report bugs on the Discord.
You can submit 6 more pumpkins to the festival.
Let's go place my pumpkin.
What's this?
Hayride of Horror.
Maze of Madness.
Jump on this thing.
Haunted house is spooky.
Award badges.
Do you recognize this spot?
Come back on Halloween night for a surprise.
Oh no, we missed it.
Play the guessing game.
What's the guessing game?
Oh wow.
Wow, how did they carve them so well?
Maybe I should have carved more.
Guys, I didn't carve enough.
Flowey, Saiyan's Undertale.
Where can I place mine?
Isn't there also...
Oh yeah, so there's different...
Yeah, there's different universes.
So we're in the classic world.
Are they all the same or are they just different servers?
So like if I went to the Forbidden World or the Forgotten World...
They're all the same?
Oh, this world is full.
It only says there's 95 people though.
How are you so tiny?
Slightly crooked enigma.
How are you small?
How are you so small?
What are you doing over here?
Are you shy?
Look, everybody is going around.
Hey, go away.
There's a creeper in the bathroom.
I wanted to put mine in there.
You scared him.
Look at all these pumpkins.
This is so cute.
What's this?
Happy Halloween.
I can't go inside.
Oh, but I can look.
I think.
Maybe we can go inside back here.
Oh, maybe.
How do we get in?
Do I have to like dig?
A mushroom.
Look out for a mushroom.
I want to go in here.
Oh my goodness.
Spooky sounds.
This is so cute.
What's in here?
Check a tree.
Pumpkin festival.
Carve pumpkins.
Show them off on the world wide web.
Welcome to scenic ghost town.
There's nobody here, TM.
Oh, is this your house?
Sorry.
Wow.
Oh, what's over here?
You forgot the pickles.
That's funny.
I like that one.
How do you fly?
Oh my gosh.
What is this?
We are on the...
Hey, I want to be able to see.
Here, I'm going to jump on.
Oh my god.
A skelly is driving this thing.
Sorry, I think I toggled the light in the world by trying to shift.
I'm trying to see.
Where are we going?
Welcome, Dusty.
What are you trying to say about me?
I'm Dusty?
Go away, computer.
Oh, I'm falling off.
I'm trying to get up top.
How do you guys get up top?
But fine.
OK, fine.
You know what?
I'll just sit here.
We are going into the hayride of horror!
Wait, will I be able to hear any sound effects?
Metal gear!
Hey, I can't see!
Who is driving this thing?
Oh my god.
I don't hear any... OK, I think I have to turn the sound effects on.
But you guys, can you not take pictures then?
Don't take pictures, because the sound is annoying.
Sorry, I clicked the main... Sorry, I'm really sleepy.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to click the main menu instead.
Skull face monologuing in front of Venom.
Sorry, I meant to go back to the settings.
OK, I can do it here though.
If you are going to take a picture, just like... Here, I'll even turn it to like 80.
There we go.
Just do a screenshot, otherwise the sound is just too annoying.
Hey!
Were you waiting here to say that?
That's crazy.
I'd rather be watching anime?
You could say that?
There are so many things here.
Wait, anime... What about VTuber?
Oh, there is nothing about VTubers.
I'd rather be... Where is your pumpkin?
I'm a... I'm a spooky ghost.
Do you think I'm rambunctious?
Is that what that said?
These are so random.
There are so many things here though.
This is really tricky.
You must have a big brain.
My brain is nice and smooth.
VTubers are niche?
You think so?
How did we get to that A-Ride?
How do you flow, you guys?
I don't know how to do anything.
Oh, there it is!
Welcome to Dusty Fields.
I'm going!
Here we go.
Time for Haunted House.
Welcome, Dusty.
Click on a mushroom.
A mushroom?
It's hazardous, you guys.
Be careful in here.
Something screamed.
Oh my god, this spider is laughing at me.
And then there is the scene from the bridge in Metal Gear Solid.
Three.
I can't see.
Her hats are in the way.
Oh my god.
Who the hell is that?
Why is there a dog in here?
No!
Oh my god, that's a real horror.
That's a real scariness.
Oh my god.
Sexy.
I think we are interrupting something here.
Oh, what's that?
Alien!
Oh my gosh.
What a freak.
Stop being weird!
Oh my gosh, it's a witch!
What's over here?
Cemetery.
Of course there would be a cemetery in the ghost town, right?
Hey, get out.
Get your big head out of my face.
That scared me.
That's me right now.
Congratulations, you survived the hayride of horror!
We did it!
Oh my gosh.
I think there is a selfie cam.
Wait.
Look at me!
Wait, can I zoom out?
How can I take a picture with... Oh my god.
There we go.
Hey, you can take your photos, I guess.
Oh, there we go.
What's this one?
Hold on, what's the other side?
Oh, I know I want to be Frankenstein.
Get out of the way, I'm Frankenstein.
Freaking paparazzi up in here.
I know.
These are so cute.
Get all your pictures everybody.
I keep wanting to sprint.
Oh my gosh.
But when you press shift...
It just...
Oh my gosh, I think I'm going to sneeze.
It changes the light.
Flashbang in 3, 2, 1.
Wait, can I go through the hayride of horrors without...
Ride may be too spooky for children under 10.
Oh my gosh, I can.
Can I go inside this house?
Oh my gosh.
There is a man here.
Let me out of here.
Get me out of here.
Oh god, I'm going to get run over.
I didn't even notice this guy here when we were on it before.
How do I find a mushroom?
I'm searching for a mushroom in the woods.
I like the alien.
It might be my favorite one.
Winnie the Pooh?
Oh, it is Winnie the Pooh.
This one is funny.
Oh, that's so good.
Look at the alien ones.
What are these creatures?
It's so interesting.
Hold on, I'm turning on the lights again.
3, 2, 1.
Oh my gosh, there is one even under there.
How is the family reunion going?
It's craziness.
I don't recognize any of these relatives.
How do we find a mushroom?
Oh, I found a mushroom.
Oh, I'm still in photo mode.
No!
I want to be able to float.
How do I float, you guys?
How do you guys fly in the air?
How are you guys doing that?
There are like little popcorns everywhere.
You have to be small to float?
I saw some big people.
Oh, I'm going to spoil myself for the...
There is a jump thing that they talked about too.
Let's go over here.
What was this?
Wait, I don't want to be small anymore.
Help!
I'm going too fast!
I don't want to be small.
Reserved for who?
Oh my god.
I don't want to be small.
Where do I become big?
It's too much.
Help me!
Back of the house.
Which house?
Which house was it?
I'm looking.
I see nothing.
Oh gosh.
I'm too small.
I want to be big again.
Oh here.
I'm normal.
Now we got to find out how to get back to that area.
Over here.
I think you need to figure out how to be tall before your afterlife.
Shut up!
We can go through here, right?
Oh yeah, we can.
Pumpkins are spawning in.
Oh there is another photo spot.
Oh my gosh.
We can be witches.
Anime cat.
Parkour.
Ok, nevermind.
I'm still...maybe I need to be...parkour.
Oh, sorry guys.
Nice.
Hmm.
Wait, no.
Want to guess which is my pumpkin?
Oh you guys are taking pictures here.
Oh my gosh, it can be a little cat!
That's so cute!
I can see it.
Let's see what's over here.
Are there secrets?
Are there any secrets in the beyond?
Woah!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Look at them go!
This guy is not amused.
Yeah buddy, get it going.
You've got this.
Oh, this one is actually my favorite.
Actually, wait.
This guy is really schmovin'.
Actually, I think this guy is my favorite.
He doesn't know at all.
He's not on beat or anything.
Oh wait, nevermind.
Oh he is on beat.
He's got this.
Go!
I'm with my friends!
I have a spooky ghost.
Oh, I didn't notice you too.
Oh yeah!
What are you doing over here, you scaredy?
Just foolish friend.
What are you doing over here?
Everybody say hi then.
Village shop.
E shop.
E shoppy.
What's in here?
Oh.
Aliens are real.
Stop paying rent.
Wow!
This is my favorite channel!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah!
I like hearing the guys go woo.
What does it say?
Run?
And then they couldn't write anything else.
I like... Oh they put this behind the tree so it looks like a cat is peeking out from the tree.
That's so silly.
I love that.
Have you seen this man?
He owes me $82.
No sferatu.
What is this?
The evil manor.
Oh!
This must be the... Wait, hold on.
Wait, I can't read it.
You guys are in the way.
I can't read it.
Please let me read it.
Please let me read the rules.
Wait.
We'll come back.
I didn't want to do it right now anyway.
There was something else over here.
There was like that jump thing too.
But I got distracted by the skellies.
There was a jump thing.
I saw it from over here.
It was like a big tower.
Not this though, I don't think.
I don't know actually.
Oh, you can go up there?
Wasn't there like a jump... Oh my god, I surprised Pikachu.
Wasn't there a jump tower?
It said to go to the jump tower.
Oh gosh, it actually made my stomach drop.
I thought I saw it.
It's on the other side of the map.
Oh, it is?
I'll go check it out.
Oh, I like this one.
It's pretty.
I was taking pictures behind me.
That's weird.
Don't just take pictures of my ass.
Hey, what is this?
The Barn of Terror?
What is this?
There is a big old spooky ghost... not ghost, skelly.
There is another skelly.
He is giving a thumbs up.
What is this?
Who is laughing?
I like how the audio is very clearly coming from here.
Is this it?
It's just another room?
I guess?
Weezer?
I see.
Weezer.
Shrek!
Wait, I hear something over here.
Oh my gosh, we can also be a part of Metal Gear Solid 3.
Or maybe it's the Lion King.
I don't see the jump area.
Am I going crazy?
I don't see it.
Oh my gosh, it's the boss and she is kicking...
She kicked Snake off the...
The bridge.
Oh, I see it over there.
I think.
Hot dog, thank you.
Speaking of stummy, happy good tummy day.
Memento perchance showeth the stummy toggle that you teased on Twitter beforeth.
Oh, there is a maze.
Okay.
I'm gonna go through the maze.
Wait, before I do...
Before I do, I do want to see if any of the other...
Worlds, the universes are...
If they have anything.
So where do we go?
To the mysterious world?
I kind of want to go to the forbidden world because you can't tell me to not go to the forbidden...
Or you can't say forbidden world and then it's...
Sorry, and then, you know...
You can't let me go.
They have more pumpkin space?
Over here, in the forbidden world.
The pumpkins are here.
So, actually, someone asked me this before.
What the hell?
This is just a normal-ass pumpkin.
Nevermind.
Someone asked me before because I once posted a picture.
Or rather, I think I showed it to you of me.
Oh, it is all the same.
But there is lots of space.
Oh my gosh, I can put mine right here.
Bring your pumpkins to the festival.
Choose a pumpkin.
The universe is almost full.
No, I don't.
Hey!
What's wrong with you guys?
You assholes!
What?
Wait, where did all these pumpkins come from?
This can't be all you.
Wait, huh?
It was completely empty just two seconds ago.
What just happened?
Oh, it didn't load in yet.
Oh...
I thought...
The skeletons have a spot?
OK.
But someone asked if I could take my skirt off before once.
And I...
Can.
Wisp love!
Oh my god!
OK, this is the... The wisps take over this area.
Oh my god, they are loading in again.
What's happening?
And...
I can take off my skirt, kind of.
I can't show you the apron because...
I'll just be full coochie out.
And I don't think YouTube would like that very much.
So...
Oh my god.
So I can't show you my stomach or else I'll just be naked.
I have to take off all my clothes.
There's room up here?
On the cliff?
I can't tell if they are loaded in or not.
I'm gonna go right here.
Place my pumpkin, sausage jack.
Place.
Place pumpkin.
Why won't it let me place it?
Oh, I have to pick a spot.
Oh, I see, I see.
Place pumpkin.
I'll have my face showing.
There it is!
My pumpkin!
It's in the forbidden world, everybody.
Team Stummy defeated.
So I can only show you my stummy on Twitter because, you know...
Like I said, it's, you know, all my clothes off and stuff.
My innocence.
No, I'm saving you.
There's four festival activities you can do to collect pins for your hat.
Ride the hayride.
Pins are next to the exit sign.
Oh, wait, where was the hayride over here, right?
A jump, parkour tower, a maze and the escape room mansion.
Okay, I want to do the escape room mansion last.
So... Oh my gosh.
Guys, how do I look?
Why do you look the sussiest face ever?
Why do you have the sussiest face ever?
Why do you...
This is so stupid.
They're all suss... Oh my gosh, they just become this...
Amalgamation of faces.
Okay, where was the hayride?
Sorry, I'm getting so lost in here.
It's not even like that big of an area, but for me I'm just like...
I'm lost.
Oh, here it is.
Over here.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so that's the maze.
We'll go in that after I get my pin.
What's this?
Trick or treat!
Let's go get the pin.
Pin for my hat.
Here?
On this thing?
Congratulations.
Oh, free pin!
I screamed on the haunted hayride.
You collected a pin.
Now you can equip a special hat.
Oh, thank you!
Let's go through the...
The maze.
If you want, you can give medals to pumpkins by pressing escape and clicking on the medal.
Oh, everybody's gotta give me medals.
What the hell happened to this guy?
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let me read.
The maze of madness.
Enter if you dare.
Oh, there's something in the middle.
Okay.
In case of emergency, hit me up.
Ignorance is folly.
I'm never gonna remember.
Let's just get lost.
One of the best things about mazes is to just get lost in it, you know?
Ow!
Get out of here.
We're just gonna get lost in it.
See?
These guys are not small and they're floating.
You guys said I had to be small to float, but they're big.
I love peanuts.
Snoopy.
Maze.
We're in the maze.
Peanuts.
Wait, did I go... Oh!
That was actually spooky with like how spooky the music was all of a sudden.
That was actually kind of spooky.
What the heck just happened?
Is it right here?
Is this where we're trying to get to?
Oh no, that's the entrance.
Here lies your mom.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on, guys.
My YouTube froze again.
As it does.
As it tends to do.
I want to say, though.
I do want to say again, though, that this is a free game.
You can check out the pinned message.
But it can accompany... Like 500 people or so can join in.
So if you are like, how do I get in?
How do I play with you guys?
Feel free to join, you know?
Okay, there we go.
Oh, this ghost wants to challenge you to the guessing game.
What's the guessing game?
The other ghosts will pick a pumpkin they've created on the map.
They'll give you up to five hints and you have to try and guess which pumpkin is theirs.
Oh.
Okay.
I need a hint.
My pumpkin is very cute.
Speak!
You're far away.
I'm far away.
Gnome!
How are you guys floating?
I can't get up as high as you guys.
What?
I wave my pookie.
What the hell?
Is it in the maze?
Your pumpkin!
Sad.
Is it this one?
Incorrect.
Oh my god.
My pumpkin is full of sadness.
What does that mean?
Was it the wisp pumpkin there?
The dancing skelly?
Oh, let's go see.
I can't get out of the maze though.
I'm actually stuck.
Wait, I keep going in circles.
My pumpkin might remind you of a friend.
Is it in the maze?
There is nothing even on this pumpkin.
I didn't even carve anything.
What's going on in there?
Oh my god!
This one reminds me... Oh my god!
Look, it's a big boss right there.
Let's keep going.
I'm trying to find the pumpkin.
It's gotta be in the maze, right?
It's a maze pumpkin.
Oh my gosh.
Hello.
Where did I come from?
Why is there just a random pumpkin in the middle of the walkway?
A
wisp!
There is another wisp pumpkin.
It's so cute.
Shut up.
Stop laughing at me.
Oh wait, I'm gonna ignore requests for now.
Thank you though.
I didn't know it would like... I thought I accidentally clicked on someone and that's why the request came.
There is too many pumpkins for me to know.
And the hints kind of suck.
The hints kind of suck.
Look how cute it is!
Look how cute!
Alright, let's see.
How do we get to the middle of this maze, guys?
How do we get to the middle?
How do we get to...
Oh no, I got gnomed.
How are you guys floating so high?
What's this?
Spooky.
Nope.
I've never been in a real hedge maze before.
Oh they are standing on the hedge tops.
How do you get up there?
Is this the egg?
Is this the...
Oh.
Wait, I forgot that we can look at the names of the things.
The names of the... What's it called?
You cheesed it.
I didn't mean to.
The names of the pumpkins.
I gotta go back and see what the names of the wisps pumpkins are.
No?
What's up here?
Wait, I want to see more pumpkins.
Now I feel like I have to look at all of them.
Their secret...
Sorry, I got something in my throat.
Sorry.
I got something in my throat.
I wonder what it's called.
Too Pleasant Pumpkin.
What does that even mean?
Woah.
Oh my god.
Oh, I thought that did not say beet.
I thought it definitely said something else.
That doesn't make any sense.
Oh, is that Isabelle?
Pretty Appalling Pumpkin.
Wait, they don't say the names of the actual names?
Like they won't say Saucy Jack for my pumpkin name?
No.
But it's called Saucy Jack.
Oh my gosh, it keeps going up.
Keeps going up.
You need to change the settings.
Oh.
Like a festival?
Pumpkin names, real.
Oh, okay, okay.
Thank you.
Oh, there we go.
Perfect.
Ah, now we can go see what the names are.
Free Pin!
I lost myself in that maze.
Lol, where am I?
We made it to the top.
Wait, I'm trying to see the pumpkins, you guys.
Trying to see the pumpkins.
Roblox face.
It's just some numbers.
It's kind of cryptic.
Wow.
Oh, there's people down there.
Oh, don't get lost.
Hold on, let's go see what that one was called.
Oh, it makes my stomach drop.
It makes my stomach drop for real.
I gotta get out of here.
Let's go find that wisp.
Where was the wisp at?
There we go.
Wisp!
You were somewhere over here.
If you guys find him, crowd around the wisp.
If you find him, crowd around the wisp.
I wanna see what his name is.
I'm starting over.
Seems like a nice fella.
I don't know about that.
Oh my gosh!
Cute!
The cool ass.
Yeah.
Saucy Jack.
That's mine.
People will see it.
Maybe not though.
Maybe no one will see it.
It's the last day.
I wish I had known about this sooner.
I'm jumping by the wisp.
Oh gosh, I'm trapped.
Hold on.
I'm looking at other ones.
Oogie boogie!
Wait, I'm trapped?
OK, hold on.
Where is the wisp?
Have you seen any other ones?
Over there?
Oh my gosh.
I see many people jumping over there.
Oh no!
I failed the parkour!
How will I become Minecraft parkour champion like this?
Yeah,
you are an odd ghost.
You are an odd ghost.
You're all like it.
Get out of here.
Can't you draw anything else?
Hold on.
Oh gosh, I have to get back up again.
Oh, it's a nerd pumpkin.
It's not big enough.
Hold on.
I have to get back up.
They are easy to make?
So is the wisp.
The wisp is easy to make.
Up.
I'm stuck.
Wait, what's this one called?
Big boss.
Oh, it's a pirate.
Man!
I'm trying to get there!
I'm coming!
Don't leave!
Stay right there!
I'm on my way.
This way.
Maybe.
No!
Not this way.
I'm coming!
This way.
This way?
I'm on my way.
Yeah!
I'm stuck.
Wisp tool.
Now we have to go to the other wisp.
Wait, I have to get out of here.
I have to find a gnome.
Gnome!
Where is a gnome when you need one?
Oh my gosh.
I found it.
Thanks guys for chilling by it.
What is this one?
Oh my gosh!
It was a yukuri!
I thought it was a yukuri, but...
OK.
Alright.
Guys, you gotta give me some space so I can see.
You guys gotta give me some space so I can see.
OK.
Exit is...
Which way is the exit?
That?
No.
What's the exit?
That's the jumpy thing, so let's go over there.
Oh!
Oopsie.
OK.
We'll find a gnome eventually.
Probably.
It's a lot of ghosts.
I know it's bopping up in here.
Gnome!
Oh my god!
We've completely taken over this entire...
We've taken over this server.
We are the... Oh, I already like this.
This forbidden...
The forbidden area is our area.
Smug pumpkin.
Wait, what does it say?
Oh, platypus!
Thank you!
The forbidden world is ours, everybody.
OK.
Let's go to the parkour, which was...
Up here?
I guess?
Oh, this area is here.
OK.
Oh, there is a...
There is a staircase.
Just kidding.
OK, here we go.
Look at all these.
They are so cute.
Phantom!
That's me!
I'm starting to get so sleepy though, guys.
So I'm gonna...
Do the parkour?
Did I do the haunted... What else was there?
We did the maze.
The parkour.
We do the...
The haunted house and the...
Parkour and escape room.
OK, perfect.
This is the parkour?
I'm guessing.
Oh, there is so many here.
Chat.
Oh my goodness, there is so many here.
OK.
Oh, we start here.
Alright.
You guys make it so busy.
How am I supposed to do this?
Can we go back to Minecraft?
No.
You're gonna freak.
I'm gonna freak.
Let Minto try.
Stop playing.
Stop.
Get off.
Get off!
Stop!
I can't see if you're going.
Where do you go from here?
Oh, like that?
OK.
Oh no!
I fell off.
I can't see anything!
It might not all be wisps.
I'm telling you...
I saw, like, one person on...
Well, unless they just decided to leave the...
Or, like, if there are people trying other servers...
Other universes.
Cause...
I saw only one person on earlier.
Just one.
Nice.
Did you just go up from here?
OK.
Where do we go from here?
Oh, over there?
I can't see.
I can't see!
OK, nice.
And then from here, where do we go?
Everybody is just cra...Oh, over there?
I was so close.
There are too many people.
Too many people!
Turn off ghost for this part?
That's such a good idea!
OK.
Options.
Festival.
Sorry guys!
See you later for a second.
OK.
This is all me.
I wonder, can you guys still see me though?
Oh!
Oh my goodness.
I fall...
What happened to this pumpkin?
Kaplooey.
I was like, it got exploded.
I kind of want to make a boo pumpkin.
I can't...I don't...I can't...
Freaking stick...
Stay on the dang thing.
OK.
OK, there we go.
I overcompensated.
I want to so badly run like in Minecraft.
But I can't.
OK.
Parkour.
Jump for the beef.
Always go beef, baby.
Beef, baby.
All in, baby.
Oh, over here.
Oh!
I don't think I jumped soon enough.
I'm not going to use a mushroom for this.
Because that's no fun.
Sorry, I'm really lagging today.
I'm lagging so much today in the brain department, everybody.
Please understand.
Ah!
I was so close.
Brain lag.
OK.
Oh come on!
I ran into that thing and it pushed me off.
Can't you see your feet?
No.
You can't see your feet.
So I have no idea what my feet look like.
Lampy, thanks for the gift!
Here is Enderpearl.
Oh my God.
We did it, everybody.
Where do I go from here?
Oh, here?
We did it!
Oh wait, there is more.
Just kidding.
Oh wait.
Oh here, just kidding.
I was just kidding.
There is more.
They just give you like a bit of a...
What's it called?
A break spot.
Hello?
Why am I...
I'm stuck?
There we go.
I keep overcompensating.
And then...
Here?
No?
Where do I...
Is it this part?
Is it over this one?
Is it this one right here?
I can't figure out what place I'm supposed to jump to.
Yes?
Ok.
And then...
Oh, that's the top.
Wait, how do I get there?
What's the correct pathway?
Oh my gosh, you know how like...
You know how in like...
Some people will complain about Resident Evil where...
It'll be like, they make things too obvious.
Like, why is there a big giant yellow X on the things that I...
On the places that I need to go.
I feel like that is necessary right now.
Where it's just like, I need big yellow splotches of paint.
On the areas that I need to jump to.
That's what I need.
Turn around?
Oh, is it this?
Oh my god.
No freaking way.
So I need to...
Wait, where do I go from here?
Ok, ok, we didn't lose so much there guys.
We're fine, we're fine.
We didn't lose so much, we didn't lose so much.
We're ok, we're ok, we're ok.
We're ok.
Everything's fine.
Oh, everything's not fine.
Oh my goodness.
Why am I having to parkour all the time?
And no matter what game I play.
What's so fun about parkour, huh?
Why does everybody love parkour, huh?
Oh my gosh, please.
I'm lagging so bad.
Not in game, but in mind and in spirit.
I was gonna say body, but...
That's also my spirit.
That was close.
Oh my god.
Maybe it'd be easier to jump right here.
Where's the top?
Reserved for who?
Obi Tower?
No problem.
Come back my wisps.
Come back.
Not main menu, sorry.
Oh my gosh, I almost did it again.
We're back!
Welcome back.
You're so clever.
Thank you.
Very good everybody.
Very good.
I wanna see the pumpkins up here.
Maybe I should have done that before I brought you guys back into the world.
Check this out.
IDK who?
It's Rem!
What do you mean IDK who?
It's Rem.
I can also...
Have a longer bangs.
I can also have a longer bangs.
Who?
Shut up.
Shrek baby.
Alright.
Time to do...
Wait.
The...
Oh my gosh.
Let's go back to the skellies and then we'll do the...
Haunted house.
Escape room.
What the hell is that thing?
Oh my gosh, I love this Grim Reaper.
It's so cute.
Oh, Pikmin.
I can't see.
What the hell is this thing?
Cut.
Ok.
You look cute with longer bangs.
Thanks.
Is that a wolf?
I don't know what that is.
The hash slinging slasher.
Thanks Shaggy's wisp.
I'm starting to get super sleepy, so...
Let's do the...
Let's do the... What's it called?
Oh my gosh.
Surprise Minto.
Oh cute!
You guys were nice to each other.
It won't load.
Oh, what the?
No, move, move, move.
Oh, missing.
Created by missing.
Spooky.
What?
No!
Hi Minto.
Hi!
Wait, what the hell just happened?
What do the numbers mean?
The numbers, what do they mean?
Where did it go?
It was never there.
Where is the haunted... Oh, the haunted house is this way, right?
Here we go.
Oh my gosh, cute!
What?
You guys, this server is cursed.
It's because it's forbidden.
Maybe.
Because it's forbidden.
Oh, it's in there.
Is
it still there?
Missing.
It's kind of creeping me out.
Lantern.
Can you go in there?
Can you fall in there?
To the endless void?
Ghost made.
Minto!
Thank you.
Server overloaded?
Maybe.
What the hell?
What is this?
Oh my gosh, Sage plus Anthony.
OK, I'm going to turn you guys off again for just a moment so I can read the rules.
Because you guys don't know how to listen and you guys don't get out of the way when I tell you to!
So I must get rid of you.
The evil manor.
Can you solve the mysteries of the evil manor?
Before entering, please take note of the following.
Progress is not synced between players.
Unlocking a door will not unlock it for others.
Collaboration is encouraged.
It's more fun to solve puzzles with friends.
Jump scares.
Use one of the following codes to enter the manor.
For a family-friendly manor, use 6660.
For bloody and spooky ambiance, use 6663.
And for blood and jump scares, use 6666.
You can adjust these later.
Progress is saved when you quit the game.
Enter if you dare!
We want the blood and the jump scares.
Hold on, let me enter first and then I'll...
I'll turn you guys back on.
Garfield.
I should have made a Metal Gear one.
Maybe I'll make one after this.
Depending on how long it takes me to do and how I'm feeling after.
Here we go.
Triangle door.
This is my first ever.
What's this?
I have one coin.
If you lose your way, you can trade a coin for guidance.
Oh, no, no, no.
What's this?
Lost.
Oh, there's something here.
I found a chest at the manor.
It seems to have the magical property of returning any lost items to me after closing and reopening it.
It's an ender chest.
This will surely come in handy as I delve deeper into the mysteries of this cursed place.
I already found the code to first...
Oh, no.
See, guys?
I'm starting to get so sleepy.
I already found the code to first safe.
But with a code like that, well, I doubt they really care about security around here.
MB.
What is it?
Like 1, 2, 3, 4, 5?
Okay.
I'm with what?
Door is locked.
Another coin.
I can't see the picture.
What's the picture?
You!
You with the stupid hat.
I can't see the picture.
Come on, guys.
Come on.
Seriously.
Come on, guys.
Come on.
Oh, there's a coin up here.
Nice.
Wait, what was there?
Okay, I'm turning you guys off.
I'm sorry.
You guys can't stop crowding around, so...
We'll just...
Sorry, everybody.
But now I'm gonna get scared because I'm by myself.
It looks like I'm by myself.
What is it?
It's a silly face.
Okay, so we have...
What's this door?
Is this locked too?
Oh, no.
Oh?
Oh, here.
The key to the safe.
Okay.
Or the code.
Probably 1, 2, 3, 4.
I knew it!
Alright, so we got the door...
Or the key to the triangle.
Sorry, no.
Diamond.
What's that sound?
Okay.
So we gotta arrange these.
Arrange them, arrange them.
I'm just gonna put them...
Let's do like 3 here.
4.
Okay, hold on.
I'm grabbing all of them first.
2.
Okay.
More.
Oh, no.
This one's smeared.
And then 6.
Okay.
1.
2.
Oh.
Hello?
2.
I don't think they're arranged by number.
I have a sneaking suspicion.
Is there any others?
Oh, here it is.
I found it.
I got it.
Okay.
So we just have to figure out...
How to arrange them.
And then...
We can probably get a code from that.
The moon.
Nope, like that.
This connects to this bat, so...
Hold on, I'm gonna move...
Move things I'm not sure of yet...
Onto the floor.
Okay, so move this...
And this...
That's not...
That's fine for now.
No?
To this bat?
Oh, nevermind.
Oh, to the cat!
To the cat!
It goes to the cat.
Okay.
Other cat has a little snot...
A little star connected at the bottom.
So this one.
And then...
Um...
Oh, okay, these go at the bottom.
So I have to move all of this...
Up one.
Oh, this...
There we go.
And then the other cat...
Can go wherever he feels like.
Because he's just a cat.
Nevermind.
And then he goes down here.
Wait, something is off.
Oh no!
I have to shift it all over?
Okay, okay, okay.
Shift, shift, shift.
Shift.
There we go.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
I'm happy I made it onto Minto's stream in some capacity.
Yeah, of course!
48962351.
Seven.
The cat is a seven.
489627351.
What the hell is that noise?
Oh, we didn't even go in here.
There's horse heads?
I'm spooked without you guys all floating around me.
It's not even on the hour.
Why are you going off?
Oh my goodness, there's lots of stuff here.
This place continues to confound.
It leaves me exhausted.
I dozed off a bit here and fell into a horrible dream.
I saw a monster with four horse heads sewn together.
I can't help but feel this is a bad omen.
Sewn together.
Seeing pumpkins and ghosts, I already miss October.
November has pumpkins.
And I'm a ghost, so...
You know?
What is that?
That's weird.
Oh.
Oh, we made it to the first room.
Okay, cool.
Steak.
Coin.
Okay, so these rotate.
They weren't horsing around.
What do I get with all these numbers though?
Oh, here.
What was it?
489.
627.
351.
We did it!
Good job, team.
This is the triangle.
The actual triangle.
The real triangle.
The realest triangle.
Yay!
Oh, and there's two coins here.
Is it going to get difficult?
Oh my gosh.
Metal Gear Solid Delta.
It's really quiet in here.
It's kind of relaxing though.
Oh no.
It's not very relaxing anymore.
Okay, I'm turning you guys back on because I'm scared.
God.
Okay.
Into the basement.
Lost!
This is a lost basket.
What else is in here?
What's that sound?
Oh.
What is this thing?
Okay, maybe we gotta find stuff here.
What the hell?
That he want a cookie.
He want a cookie.
You can get pictures here?
What is this?
Apple.
Oh goodness, there's so much stuff around here.
Okay, the door is locked.
And then there's another code here.
Okay.
Is there anything that I didn't do yet?
This room?
The horse sewn together.
Saw a monster with four horse heads sewn together.
Yeah, the horses.
I don't feel like I can just brute force it though.
How do I make them sewn together?
Oh, what's happening?
Oh, I clicked on a person by accident.
Oh wait.
Is that why this is sewn?
Is that why there's a...
Oh.
I get it.
S...
E...
W...
N!
Excuse me.
Thank you.
What did I get?
Where did we see this one?
The little pine.
Oh, you guys can't see it.
It looks like a pine tree.
Oh, so they gave a hint.
That's so clever.
Oh.
I see, I see, I see.
That was a spooky door.
Was it down here?
Oh wait, what was this one again?
Nope, not in there.
Not that.
Where is this?
Oh, upstairs?
I forgot that there was stuff upstairs.
Oh, here!
Ok.
Alrighty.
Hello?
Stop it!
Whoa, video game!
Uh oh.
Wait.
Oh gosh, I can't read.
1...
A...
2...
F...
What is this on here though?
They are hacking?
They are literally in the matrix right now.
Does this open?
No.
There is more in here too.
Oh, more coins!
Let's go.
Why is there just a bust of Cthulhu?
The bust of Cthulhu.
Go away!
This is...what?
They are learning their ABC's and they are just like 1, 2, 6, 6, 6.
Oh my god, bloody child!
What is this?
Oh, what is this?
Tie?
Hall?
Ok, wait.
So, if I...circle is square.
If square then...ok.
X is...oh wait, oh gosh.
It's like rock, paper, scissors.
Yeah, but I don't know the rules.
Ok, hold on.
I was wondering why it was so empty, but I forgot I also turned off other goals to focus on the puzzles, right?
So, if X...ok.
Square is...no.
X is circle.
Circle is square.
Square is X.
Square is X!
Easy!
Also, I got some scissors too.
Nice.
Oh, ok.
We can only carry one thing at a time, it seems.
But, if we need scissors, we got those.
Oh, teardrop.
Here it is.
Oh my god.
Sorry for disturbing.
Sorry for the intrusion.
It's so fun that everybody can just play these by themselves, you know?
The wall is mysteriously whispering at us.
These...ok, I can't read.
Hold on.
I can't read it.
Ok, there we go.
All these numbers have something in common.
Oh no.
They all equal 10?
Something doesn't add up.
Or does it?
The squares represent missing digits.
Oh, it's math.
It's math.
What do all these numbers have in common?
Are they divisible by something?
And they all equal 10, so it would be 5, 5, 4, 6, 3, 7...
So it would be 5, 6...
5, 6, 7, 9?
Oh!
That worked.
Ok.
I think I'm a genius after all.
I think I might be a genius after all.
I think I place this object down here.
I'm guessing.
Let's maybe take the scissors as well.
And do that too.
Oh my goodness.
I'm flying.
I'm freaking out.
Ok.
Oh, I found another coin.
I'm the coin genius.
What was that?
What was that sound?
You got the rock and the scissors?
True!
Yeah, we got rock, scissors!
True, true, true.
So what is something that we haven't solved?
But there are 4 things.
4 things.
Oh, here.
I didn't see this because it was surrounded.
The treasure inside guarded by 3 fearsome monsters.
Defeat them and the prize shall be yours.
Oh, this is where the prize or the rock, paper, scissors is I think.
But how do I know which one is rock and which one is paper and which one is scissors?
Or just, you know?
How do I know which one is the rock, paper and the scissor?
By the shape?
Oh, so you think maybe...
This is scissor.
And this is rock.
And then this would be paper?
Ok.
Ok, ok.
Defeat them though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So what haven't I solved, everybody?
What have I not solved?
The chess, maybe?
Oh, this one.
Is it the chess?
Chess puzzle.
It can't just be 1, 2, 3, 4... wait.
Is it 1...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
4...
5...
1, 6, 4, 5...
7...
4?
Look at the computer.
What's it teaching me?
The laptop shows you which pieces how they move.
I don't get it.
Wait.
I don't get it at all.
This confused me even more.
Look at the order.
I don't know how chess moves.
Wait, I don't know how each piece moves.
So that one is... is that the horse?
Is that the horse?
Erica,
help me!
I don't know.
Horse is... is eye-shaped?
Bishop is the funny hat.
Tower is the rook.
This is the queen, that's the king, right?
And then that's the bishop, that's the pawn.
The castle is the rook, right?
Wait.
Guys, I might... I might... I'm gonna go use a coin.
There are a few puzzles in the basement, but you should try opening the safe in front of the white backdrop next.
Wait.
Safe in front of... is that this one?
Is this considered a white backdrop?
It didn't even help me!
It didn't even tell me!
I don't know, chess!
No, I think it... you guys, I think it meant there are things in the basement to do, but you should open the...
Oh, this one!
Oh, this one with the white backdrop.
Cheese!
Maybe I go into photo mode.
Selfie cam.
Is there anything back here, actually?
Oh my god, I look so silly.
I look so silly.
Do I need to... oh my god, he's staring at me too.
Do I need the filter?
Maybe something that I can only see with the filter on.
This filter?
Am I thinking too much into it?
Do I take a picture here?
Let's try it.
Oh my god!
6, 6, 4, 8.
Wow!
That looks like Shrek right there.
That's so cool!
Oh, wait, oh, nope, that's not what I meant.
6, 6, 4, 8.
Yay!
This one looks like the kanji for in.
Kind of.
Is it this one?
Oh,
nasty.
Gross.
We have to determine the order somehow.
Let's, hold on, before we do that...
Door is locked.
Spooky!
Maybe it's by size?
This, this one might go here, right?
This one here.
Okay.
What's the, huh?
So we got the first one.
There's like no paper that explains what the other ones will be then.
Sort by size.
By number of sides.
Yeah, but then what's the other two?
Okay, so two...
Oh, wait.
You.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Wait, does this one have more than this one?
I'm too tired for this.
I don't think so.
This one has more, right?
More faces, technically.
Yay!
Okay, so now Roy, G, Biv.
Red.
Orange.
Roy.
G.
Biv.
Yay!
I don't know what the last one could be though.
What could the last one be?
We did number of sides.
We did...
I did the size.
Reverse size?
Oh, we could try reverse size.
Yeah, maybe.
No.
Oh, it...
It counts as size, I think.
As normal size.
Sides...
Shapes...
Colors...
Sound?
How would I even know that?
Huh?
The sound they make when you place them?
How would I...
By pitch?
Low to high?
It's highest.
Never mind, it's the highest.
Wait.
Shows a wavelength?
Oh, it does, you're right.
You're right.
Cool.
I think I got it.
No!
Wasn't it?
They...
Are each dice...
The square is a D100, the square is a D6.
But I already did the sides...
Side...
Sides one.
I don't think...
I guess we'll see if doing it in reverse...
Change it.
Oh, it did actually change it!
Oh my gosh.
Because when I did it...
In terms of size...
It was the same thing.
Not this again.
What's in here?
It's the child.
What am I...
What did I just...
Oh, the coin.
So this is equal to 10?
4, 2...
0...
8?
4, 2, 0...
Yeah!
I'm a genius!
Where was this room?
Wait...
It's like a little...
Oh, here it is.
I'm turning the ghost back on!
You guys, come out!
You're my...
What's it called?
My...
Like the pets that you bring around that make you feel good.
Oh, I have to get small for this one.
3 o'clock?
Emotional support ghost.
This is so in-depth though.
Isn't it kind of crazy?
No, nothing there.
Tick-tock.
Anything in here?
No?
And then there's a maze.
And then...
There's...
Oh, we can go in here?
What's this?
Can you go in here?
Eventually maybe?
Other people are going in and out.
Oh no!
Also, if you try to give me any hints while I'm playing, do not.
Don't give me any hints, okay?
No hints.
Don't try to show me anything, okay?
So if you're like, look, you can go through the mirror, don't show me.
I wanna see it myself.
How do I make myself smaller though?
Were there any mushrooms about?
Did you guys see any mushrooms?
Mushrooms?
Smile out the spoilers.
We can't!
You guys, I still need to figure out this one.
Can you guys just tell me?
You can at least help me with this one, right?
Because I don't know anything about chess.
And I'm tired.
7, 8, 5, 3, 2, 1.
Thank you.
You
said no help.
Only with this one.
Because I don't know anything about chess.
It was a genuine cry, you guys.
It wasn't just me being like, help me.
It was a genuine cry.
Oh, is there any mushrooms here?
To make me small.
Maybe not.
Dang it.
After exploring the secret room behind the office, I thought I'd take a moment to rest here.
I've decided to leave my spare notepad here to lighten my pack.
I sure hope no one takes it while I'm gone.
I'll take it.
Oh, paper!
We got the paper.
Okay.
Okay, so...
Rock beats scissors.
Oops.
Paper beats rock.
Scissors beats paper.
Yay!
It's an up arrow.
Oh, there's something in here though.
The shed code is 0513.
0513.
Remember that, guys.
0513 for the shed.
We haven't gone outside yet.
This is... where is this one?
Up here, maybe?
No.
In here, maybe?
Where was this one?
I can't remember.
They're all blending together.
This one's the stairs?
Stairs?
I never even tried opening that one.
It was next to me?
In the basement?
Thank you!
I'm so sorry.
What's happening?
We're outside!
Oh my gosh.
Charlotte.
Wait, a hole?
Is it negative what?
From what I know, there should be a clue in the graveyard to give me access to the red safe.
But I can't seem to figure it out.
Perhaps I don't have all the information I need yet.
I should come back later when I've made more progress elsewhere.
Delilah.
1893.
This person doesn't get a name.
Mint Phantom.
Oh no!
Benjamin!
Benjamin.
And this one's broken.
I'm just being dug out.
Oh my goodness.
Hey everybody!
We're doing the...
The...
The room.
Okay.
In case you forgot the code to the shed, please check the blue page.
Oh yeah, yeah.
So it was what?
0, 5, 1, 3?
Yeah.
Amelia!
Oh no!
Oh no, Amelia!
Was there... There was a safe in here?
So wait...
The first ones were easy and now I'm confused.
This one looks like the one from...
Enoch!
It is the guy from over the garden wall!
That's so funny.
It said there was a...
A red...
Safe.
What was...
Oh, the red safe was...
I think in the bathroom.
But they're all spread out.
Okay, hold on.
So...
19, 20, blank.
Or no, 8, yeah.
18, 20, blank.
Please no photos.
20, 90, blank.
1940, blank.
Not this again.
Yeah, I
think the blanks are the numbers we need, but...
So do those numbers...
What do they equal up to?
They can't...
These can't equal up to 10, right?
Unless...
Hold on, how much does this one equal up to?
Let's see.
16.
Oh, so 20!
Oh, I think we go up to 20 now.
Okay, so...
12, 8.
So Delilah is 8.
Um...
And then they're also... It's A, B, C.
Okay, hold on.
I might need you guys to...
I've got it.
Go eat snacks.
Enjoy your snacks!
Okay, hold on.
So Amelia...
Let's do it in order order.
So this is...
14, uh, 6.
So 6...
6, 9...
Charlotte, 9...
8?
6, 9, 9, 8?
Will that be it?
Let's go try.
Where was the...
Red...
The red...
Oh, all the doors are shut all of a sudden.
Why?
So kind of spooky.
Is it this one?
Yeah, yeah, okay.
6, 9, 9, 8.
Yay!
Oh my gosh, guys.
We're a genius!
3.
Let's go!
What have we not done?
I think we did everything up in these rooms.
Yeah.
I think upstairs is done.
And then there's a bunch of...
Oh!
Oh gosh.
This didn't have anything else out here, did it?
I still have to be able to find a way to get small.
I think.
I don't know what's in there.
This little guy is here, but then also...
In the shower.
Okay, there's a lot of stuff in here, I feel like.
Why are you in here?
Like, there's also this thing.
Soap.
I don't know what's a hint and what's ambiance.
Like, where is even a maze at?
I don't even know.
Unless this is a thing for the lock.
Let's see.
Up.
Left.
Right.
Let's see.
Stop!
Oh no, wait.
No!
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I have to turn you guys off.
Okay.
Up.
Left.
Right.
No.
And then this.
Tick-tock, but...
What do I put here?
This one confuses me.
Oh, until the exit?
Oh, you think?
Okay.
Up.
Right.
Or up.
Left.
Up.
Right.
Up?
Right?
I wonder if it's...
If it counts, like if it wants you to...
I think it means... Yeah, wait.
I think it wants you to do it at every turn, right?
So, wait, would it be up?
Up then.
Oh no.
Just turns?
Okay, okay.
So, up.
Left.
Up.
Right.
Left.
Up.
Okay, let's try it.
Left.
Up.
Right.
Wait.
Up.
Left.
Right.
Up.
Left.
Ah!
Thank you guys!
Okay, so I had the idea.
Thank you for the little...
Little... for writing it out for me.
Thank you.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
Yippee!
Oh, I think we can go in now.
Mirror, mirror, on the wall.
Oh!
We can be small now!
Cheese.
Oh my gosh.
Satanic cheese.
Demon summoning for culinary purposes.
Lips, butt, ear, nose.
Lips.
Nice.
Lips, butt.
Oh, do I have to do it here too?
Huh.
Oh, Mr. Mouth.
It's kind of freaky.
Do you think I have to do it again?
Also, where do I get the lips, butt, ear, mouth?
Is it mirrored?
It probably is.
If someone doesn't mind...
Writing it out again, but mirrored...
I would really, really appreciate it.
Original was up.
Okay.
Up, left, up, right, up.
Wait, okay.
Up, right.
Eat the mushroom.
Oh, that's all it was.
Oh, but we needed the hand!
Oh, this is the lips hand!
Okay, awesome.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Perfect.
Okay, let's go deliver this.
To the basement.
And it was... I don't remember the order.
So this isn't a three.
Oh, this is an ear.
Alright.
We're all good.
Let's go to the kitchen because the book said for culinary purposes.
Or maybe... No, we just need to get the hands and put them in the order.
I think.
I think we're done in here.
Yeah, there's nothing else.
Okay, what else have we... Oh, the TikToks.
And that door is still locked.
Yeah, we need two more hands.
I don't understand this one at all.
Like, this part confuses me.
Are there three floors?
I guess technically if you include the basement.
Is basement this floor?
Sorry.
And then the top floor.
But this one is a jump scare.
It doesn't do anything.
And so is the same as this door.
It's a jump scare door.
Oh, there's a coin.
Thank you.
Another coin.
I'm gonna find all the coins in this place.
I'm gonna get an achievement for finding all the coins.
Bless you.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I see what you mean.
That there needs to be maybe a clock on...
Like each floor.
But it won't let me adjust the clocks.
I can just go to them.
Unless we see what time each one says.
Let's see if we can find one.
Oh, here!
6...610?
No.
Wait.
710?
711?
710, 11?
Okay.
Oh, that's the light I'm hearing.
Okay, I thought it was a clock that I was hearing.
Okay.
Do I add all the times together, I wonder?
This one is...
10...11?
Also, it's the same as the other one.
Or 1012, maybe?
10PM?
And then the basement.
Is this how escape rooms usually are?
It's pretty fun.
I don't remember seeing a...
Oh, here!
Oh, now it's 9...7!
So, 7, 10, 7.
But
that was 7 on the dot.
Or unless they want us to put the 19.
No, no, I think 7?
10?
7!
What the hell is going on in here?
Oh my god.
Oh, what?
We have to figure out the numbers?
The numbers?
What do they mean?
Which one do we...
Paragon, paragon.
So...
5...111...4?
Did I press it too many times?
No, ok.
5...
5, 1.
Oh wait, how are you supposed to know which one it is?
How are you supposed to know which one it is?
Yeah, you're right.
These ones have... Oh my god.
These ones have 3 moons.
I just noticed.
You're right.
Ok.
Oh, this is really big brain.
Ok, so we have to use the other ones to kind of...
Get a gauge.
So which ones are the same?
So I think it's always 5.
It's 5, 1 I think.
It's 5, 1.
Or... Yeah, 5, 1.
We can figure this out.
Yeah, 4 is the last one.
5, 1...
5, 1, 3?
5, 1, 3...
Something 4.
Ok, hold on.
5, 1, 3...
2.
5, 1...
5, 1, 3...
2, 4...
There it is.
We need to go small I think.
Oh yeah.
Oh wait, over here.
That wasn't so bad everybody.
What does this say?
There is supposed to be a 4th clock.
But I've searched everywhere, inside the manor, across all the festival grounds, even in alternate universes.
I just can't find it.
Sigh.
From everything I've researched, the time on that clock is the key I need.
Although I might never be able to find that clock, maybe the person reading this will have the power to search places outside of my realm of existence.
Luckily this keypad seems optional.
I'll pass on this for now.
Outside of their realm of existence?
Outside of my realm of existence?
My computer clock you think?
No way.
How would they want me to put it in I wonder.
But...
The game runs locally.
True, true, true.
Oh my gosh, that's so cool.
This is such a fun little...
Sorry, I forgot.
I probably should have done this first.
It's 9.21 for me.
Oh my god!
What is this?
Wait, what is this game?
Oh?
Web fishing?
I thought it was a short hike.
It is a short hike?
Oh, I thought so.
I wonder if this... It says it's optional.
I wonder if...
I wonder if it was like, you know, back when this was first started.
This pumpkin festival tradition.
I wonder if this was... A short hike was not out yet and so...
Maybe it was like a preview or something.
No, you can't play it unfortunately.
I'm trying...
I'm trying the arrow keys too, but it doesn't seem to work.
Oh, it's not a short hike.
Are you sure?
It really looks like it, but I don't recognize this character.
I don't know.
Okay, well, what have I not...
Gotten yet now?
We're missing...
We're missing the nose.
Where is she?
Where is the nose?
Is there any puzzles I haven't done yet?
This doesn't open.
There was a red chest outside?
There was?
More in the backyard?
I'll go check.
Let's go check.
The office.
What's the office?
We went in here too, right?
There was nothing else in here?
Yeah.
We did everything?
We did everything in here.
Where's the office?
Yeah, he did mention an office upstairs.
Oh yeah, thank you.
It was this one, right?
This?
Oh wait, what did I just click?
Oh, coin.
The digits always add up to the same thing.
I didn't even realize the bonus hint.
We didn't need it, we're too smart.
Office is upstairs.
Yeah, it's the office, right?
It seems office-y.
What was the...
No, that said that though, I don't remember.
I don't remember.
Did it say something about a painting in here?
Look closer.
Oh, the secret room!
That's right.
It's a horse girl.
Horse.
Wait, there was a creepy little plushie.
There was a creepy little plushie here.
Did you guys see it?
Does it move when I...
Oh my god, quantum horse.
Quantum horse!
Oh my god.
Okay, actually I need to turn off the ghosties for this.
I'm sorry guys, sorry!
Hi and goodbye!
Hi and goodbye.
And four...
Six...
Eight...
Four...
Six!
Wait, what was it?
Four, six...
Quantum horse.
That's so creepy.
Quantum... Oh my god!
Horses!
The... Wait, tale of the horse.
Horse.
I love this quantum room.
Oh, it's an upside-down horse.
There's so many horse... Oh my god.
Everything is on this side of the room now.
There's so many horses.
Okay, let's leave.
We got it!
What is it about this game?
I think it's me being so...
Susceptible because I'm tired.
It's like everytime I jump my stomach actually drops like I'm on a rollercoaster.
Wait.
Emotional support.
Just in case there's any jump scares.
Jump scares.
Wow, this is a long hallway.
Hello!
Hi!
Everybody is here.
Thanks for making way for me.
Red means scary.
That sure was a pretty haunted house.
You did it.
You solved Scoundrel.
Happy Halloween.
Click to teleport back to lobby.
I'm not alive, but that was great.
That was so fun.
I love this guy.
Can I get a water?
Alright, teleport.
That was so much fun.
This was such a fun little thing.
I know I wish I had known about it before Halloween.
So that we could have done it during spooky month.
But, you know, it's so...
This one is so cool, right?
This one is crazy.
It's still...
At least fall, so...
Yeah, we were able to do it at least during the fall time, you know?
How high can you go?
How high can I go?
Oh my god, they look like...
They look like little bubbles floating everywhere.
This was so cute though.
Next year I will do it again.
If they add new stuff, you know?
But for sure, if I can remember, I will at least add a pumpkin.
And I'll tell you which area the pumpkin is in.
So you can go try and find it.
But this was so much fun.
Thank you guys.
Sorry for being a little low energy since I'm so sleepy.
But I had fun.
Hold on, I wanna go on this again.
We can just kind of park ourselves right there.
I stretch.
Sleep time for me.
Thank you guys, everybody who also joined in.
Thank you all the little ghosties.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, I forgot that they screamed in this.
I was really excited about this one because I knew that so many people could join in.
And it's also free.
So, you know, I saw that some people were sad with the web phishing.
That I made the code for just members to be able to join even though it was a public stream.
And honestly, the only reason I did that was because...
Was because the game...
Oops.
Was because the game was so easily able to be hacked.
That's the only reason I made it so that it wasn't a quote-unquote public code.
But I'm really sorry if that made people feel like, you know...
I don't want anyone ever to feel like that I don't appreciate them.
Even if they can or can't afford to pay for membership or anything like that.
So, I'm really sorry.
And...
So at least with this, we could have lots and lots of people join.
So, goodbye fellow ghost.
Goodbye fellow ghost!
Wait, hold on.
I want to be big.
Back to being big.
Got to find it.
Since, you know, I really do appreciate everybody...
Even just, you know...
Anybody just watching me is very much...
Always appreciated, so...
At least with this, so many people could join.
And it's a free game, so...
Yeah, and it's safe because there's not like a chat or anything.
It's like, they're just the free...
Where is the dang mushroom?
There's just the free, the little chat that they have in here instead.
Oh, here it is.
So yeah.
Thank you guys!
I'm gonna go camera mode.
Selfie.
Get in guys!
Get in!
Get in behind me!
Behind me!
Stop getting so close!
Stop showing your camera in my face!
Get behind me!
Oh my god.
You guys don't listen well.
Come on.
There we go.
Goodbye fellow ghost.
I'm gonna freak!
Alright, everybody on the count of three...
Say, I'm gonna freak!
Wait, where is it?
One!
Two!
Three!
I'm gonna freak!
Freak!
Thank you guys!
Otsuminto!
See you guys tomorrow or whenever I see you next.
Bye bye!
Thank you!
Good night!